lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
probar la fórmula de suma de ángulos
para hacer en particular probar que el
seno de x +
x +
es igual a
igual al seno de x por el coseno ahí se
me olvidó aquí la x seno de x por el
coche no deje más el cruce no de x por
el seno de ella y la forma en que voy a
hacer esto es usando esta figura de acá
pueden ver que tiene este triángulo
rectángulo rojo bueno que estoy
iluminando en rojo que tiene una
hipotenusa de 1 también podemos decir
que es el triángulo adc y está encima de
otro triángulo su base es la hipotenusa
de ese triángulo de acá abajo el acb el
cual voy a resaltar en azul el mismo
color que tiene el ángulo de este
triángulo elche
tenemos que adc la base hace que es la
base de nuestro triángulo a veces es la
hipotenusa del triángulo a veces que
estoy terminando de colorear en azul
están uno encima de otro la forma en que
vamos a analizar esto es que primero si
lo vemos que va a ser el seno de x más
bueno x más es todo este ángulo de aquí
abajo y si vemos este otro triángulo
rectángulo
de f sabemos que el seno de un ángulo es
el lado opuesto entre la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa de este triángulo es 1 así
que el seno de ese triángulo es el lado
opuesto entre 1 así que el seno de este
ángulo de x massieu va a ser igual a la
longitud del segmento de f
lo que quiero hacer
encontrar la longitud de este segmento
de f
en este segmento lo podemos descomponer
en el segmento d y la longitud del
segmento f
podemos decir que el segmento de f que
es lo mismo que el seno de x mayer es
igual a la longitud del segmento d
más la longitud del segmento efe
y la longitud del segmento f va a ser
igual a la longitud del segmento se ve
esto de aquí sbf es un rectángulo
así que f es igual a cb así que esto va
a ser igual a de la longitud del
segmento d
la longitud del segmento se ve
nuevamente la forma en que vamos a
analizar esto es que tenemos este seno
de x más bien que es la longitud de este
segmento de f y df puede descomponerse
en dos segmentos la longitud del
segmento de y la longitud del segmento
cb ahora con esto como pista los invito
a que calculen cuál es la longitud del
segmento d
en términos de x james senos y cosenos y
también encontrar la longitud del
segmento se ve en estos mismos términos
de x
senos y cosenos traten de encontrar lo
más que puedan por su cuenta y quizás
encuentre la longitud de estos dos
segmentos asumiendo que esto ustedes ya
lo intentaron bueno sabemos que
esencialmente el seno de x más yes puede
expresarse con estos dos elementos y eso
lo quiero hacer mediante la mayor
cantidad de ángulos y longitudes
posibles de lo que tengo acá
analicemos este triángulo rojo que está
aquí encima su hipotenusa tiene longitud
1 cuál va a ser la longitud del segmento
de s
bueno ese es el lado opuesto del ángulo
x y sabemos que el seno de x es igual al
lado opuesto entre la hipotenusa que es
lo mismo que s entre 1 y s entre 1 es
igual a de s la longitud de esta parte
de acá es igual al seno de x usemos la
misma lógica el coseno de x es igual al
lado acreciente entre la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa es 1 el segmento hace es
coseno de x
esto está interesante
sabemos que podemos encontrar de este
triángulo de aquí abajo
el triángulo acb como podemos encontrar
la longitud del lado se ve bueno sabemos
que el seno de iu va a ser igual al lado
opuesto entre la hipotenusa vamos a
escribirlo el seno de iu es igual a la
longitud del segmento cb entre la
hipotenusa y aquí vemos que la
hipotenusa es el coseno de x y creo que
ustedes ya se pueden imaginar por dónde
va el asunto en el momento en el que
ustedes sientan que ya pueden encontrar
la respuesta los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolver así que la
longitud del segmento se ve que es lo
que nos interesa si multiplicamos ambos
lados por coseno de x nos va a quedar
que la longitud del segmento seve es
igual al coseno de x por el seno de iu
lo que es interesante acabamos de probar
que esto de aquí es esto de aquí arriba
así que para contactar nuestra prueba
nuestra demostración necesitamos
demostrar que este segmento d es igual a
lo que está aquí arriba el seno de x por
el coseno de james y eso es igual a esto
y aquello es igual a esto otro pues ya
sabremos que la suma de estos dos es
igual al seno de x más hacer es igual a
la longitud de f que es a su vez igual
al seno de x más veamos entonces podemos
encontrar la longitud de b bueno qué
ángulo nos puede ser útil aquí pues
primero tendríamos que encontrar este
ángulo de acá o este ángulo de aquí
abajo
creo que podemos encontrar el valor de
este ángulo
y entonces lo podemos expresar en
términos de algo con el seno de x
bueno sabemos que este es el ángulo y y
también sabemos que este es un ángulo
recto así que ese es paralelo al
segmento ave así que podemos ver el
segmento hace como una transversal y si
ese es el ángulo y
entonces sabemos que este ángulo de aquí
también va a ser nuevamente si hace esto
una transversal ya que a b y s son
paralelos entonces este ángulo de cárcer
allí y si éste es estar acá será 90
menos y si este de acá de 90 grados y
eso es 90 - entonces estos dos ángulos
combinados nos darán 180 menos y si la
suma de estos tres tiene que dar 180
pues entonces el ángulo de aquí arriba
debe ser igual a ye yé más 90 menos
yemas 90 es igual a 180 y esto es útil
para nosotros ya que ahora podemos
expresar el segmento d
en términos de g y seno de x bueno este
segmento d con respecto a y es un lado
adyacente así que va a ser un coche no
sabemos que al coseno del ángulo y del
triángulo de s
aquí sabemos que el coche no deje es
igual al segmento de entre su hipotenusa
que es el seno de equis y ahorita ya
deben de estarse emocionando porque ya
están vislumbrando la respuesta ya que
acabamos de probar al multiplicar ambos
lados por seno de x que el segmento d
es igual a seno de x por coseno de ella
así que acabamos de demostrar que esto
esto y esto son iguales ya habíamos
probado que se ve es igual a este otro
así que la suma de y se ve que es lo
mismo que la suma
efe es el seno de x más bien que es esta
fórmula de acá así que hemos terminado
hemos demostrado que la fórmula para la
suma de ángulos en el seno es correcta